Alex says, I have a deck building site
in a smaller town, population 30K,
ranking number one organically.
I have a client on the line for the free leads.
Should I run some ads to increase calls
even though I'm already ranking number one organically?
Yes, yes, yes, and yes, and it will help.
Okay, let me prove this to you.
Alex, gotta call it in.
Okay, I got a call from my concrete guy,
and if you were on my interview with Juan,
you will hear me and turn to, hey, I'm on Zoom,
I'll call you back.
So as you can see, I'm ranked number one.
My GMB fluctuates right now.
It's getting its ass handed to it, which kinda sucks,
but we just barely did citations and new review today.
But I am number one for most all terms.
I am number one organically, just like your site, right?
And I'm also running ads because when my ads are down,
there's a verification issue or any of this shit,
there's a significant drop.
Even though I'm number one,
there are still a lot of people
that are clicking and paying for,
it's charging me, they're clicking on these, okay?
So yes, it will help.
Yes, you will get different leads.
You will see some overlap.
Some of those people you could argue,
yeah, they would've called you anyway,
but I would definitely,
if you're trying to speed this process up,
throw up an ad, speed this up,
because as Juan was saying today on the interview,
it's all about that sizzle, right?
You guys, sending three leads in three days
is significantly different than sending three leads
over the course of a week or two weeks, okay?
You have a much higher chance of closing that person
if it's the lead, lead, lead,
than if it's lead two, three days, lead,
three, four days, lead.
The momentum's gone.
The sizzle is gone, okay?
So yes, answer your question, yes, Alex.